H
A SERIOUS INVESTIGATION INTO
CHILD ABUSE AND GETTING
ARRESTED.
WITH 33 DAYS UNTIL THE MIDTERMS,
DEMOCRATS ARE PANICKING.
INFLATION IS OUT OF CONTROL,
VIOLENT CRIME ON THE RISE
EVERYWHERE, THE BORDER IS WIDE
OPEN AND NOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS SPENDING
$300 MILLION ON ANTI-RADIATION
DRUGS AMID VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
NUCLEAR THREAT?
IS THAT HIS PLAN?
I HOPE HE HAS A BETTER PLAN THAN
THAT.
GAS PRICES ARE HIGH AND THEY ARE
GETTING HIGHER EVERY DAY PERIODS
PLAN BEGGING OPEC AND THE GUY HE
CALLED THE MURDERER OF
JAMAL KHASHOGGI FROM THE PARIAH
NATION OF SAUDI ARABIA DIDN'T
WORK.
HIS NEW PLAN IS TO BRIBE THE
MURDERING DICTATOR, THUG -- THAT
REEKS OF DESPERATION.
HIS DECISION TO DRAIN OUR
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVES TO
SALVAGE A FEW BOATS IS PUTTING
OUR COUNTRY'S NATIONAL SECURITY
AT RISK.
IT IS NOT A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
WHEN DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THEY ARE
GOING TO LOSE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
TO TAP INTO THOSE EMERGENCY
RESERVES.
HE IS DRAINING ALL OF OUR
PETROLEUM RESERVES.
IT'S NOW AT A 40 YEAR LOW TO
ARTIFICIALLY INCREASE THE WORLD
SUPPLY IN THE HOPES IT WILL
TEMPORARILY LOWER PRICES AT THE
PUMP, ALL FOR THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
NOW JOE BIDEN HE DOESN'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT ANY OF IT.
INSTEAD HE IS ROLLING OUT A
POLITICAL HAIL MARY AND TO DATE
ONE YEAR AFTER FIRING OR
SUSPENDING DOZENS OF WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS FOR PAST MARIJUANA USE,
HE ANNOUNCED A WIDESPREAD PARDON
TO ANYBODY CONVICTED OF
MARIJUANA POSSESSION ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
THIS ONLY INVOLVES CHARGES AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, IT COULD
INCLUDE A HUGE NUMBER OF DRUG
TRAFFICKERS AND GANG MEMBERS
THAT PLED DOWN TO SIMPLE
POSSESSION.
PENNSYLVANIA'S TRUST FUND BRAT
AND A HOODIE THAT NEVER WORKED A
DAY AND HIS LIFE ALTHOUGH HE
PRETENDS TO JOHN FETTERMAN IS
OVERJOYED.
TWEETING OUT WE DID IT, WE DID
IT!
HE DOESN'T BELIEVE THAT ANYONE
SHOULD BE IN PRISON, HE WANTS TO
LEGALIZE NOT JUST MARIJUANA OR
OTHER HARD DRUGS.
HE WANTS TAXPAYERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA TO FUND SAFE
SHOOTING ZONES.
OTHER PARTS OF PENNSYLVANIA --
HE HAS ALSO CALLED FOR PRISONS
TO BE EMPTIED BY AT LEAST A
THIRD.
AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HE TRIED
TO FREE MULTIPLE VIOLENT
MURDERERS, THAT INCLUDE ONE MAN
WHO WAS SENTENCED TO LIFE FOR
KILLING SOMEONE WITH GARDEN
SHEARS IN A PARKING GARAGE,
ANOTHER FELON WHO KILLED A WOMAN
BY STABBING HER IN THE CHEST
WITH A PAIR OF SCISSORS.
UP A NEW AD DETAILS THIS
HORRIFIC MURDER, TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE BRUTALLY MURDERED HIS
GIRLFRIENDS MOTHER WITH A PAIR
OF SCISSORS, CONVICTED OF
FIRST-DEGREE MURDER HE IS
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE.
JOHN FETTERMAN WAS THE ONLY
MEMBER OF THE PARDON BOARD TO
VOTE FOR HIS RELEASE.
JOHN FETTERMAN WANTS RUTHLESS
KILLERS BACK ON OUR STREETS.
>> Sean: 33 DAYS UNTIL THE
MIDTERMS HE'S NEVER BEEN ASKED A
QUESTION BY THE MEDIA MOB HE HAS
NEVER HAD TO EXPLAIN WHY HE
ATTEMPTED TO GET SO MANY
CONVICTED MURDERERS FREE IN
PRISON.
AFTER A STROKE HE HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO DEBATE DR. OZ AND
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS FROM
ANYBODY IN THE MEDIA AND HIS
VERY BRIEF CAMPAIGN EVENTS ARE
FEW AND FAR BETWEEN FOR GOOD
REASON -- TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO BE
A TIGHT RACE AND WE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN RUNNING LIKE WE ARE DOWN
FIVE POINTS BECAUSE WE KNOW WHAT
THE STEAK IS AT THE RACE HERE.
>> Sean: 33 DAYS YOU GET TO
DECIDE IF YOU WANT A LAZY,
DEADBEAT MENTALLY DEFICIENT
RADICAL SOCIALIST WHO LIVED OFF
MOMMY AND DADDY HIS ENTIRE LIFE,
DIDN'T PAY TAXES BUT WANTS TO
RAISE YOURS, PRETENDS TO BE A
BLUE-COLLAR WORKER IN A HOODIE.
JOHN FETTERMAN, THERE IS YOUR
GUY.
HE MIGHT NOT SHOW UP FOR WORK,
HE DIDN'T AS MAYOR.
HE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO READ AND
WRITE LEGISLATION WE DON'T KNOW
HE WON'T RELEASE MEDICAL RECORDS
BUT HE WILL ALWAYS BE HAPPY TO
FLASHES TATTOOS AS IF HE'S THE
WORKING MAN.
PAID FOR BY HIS RICH MOMMY AND
DADDY.
MEANWHILE HE SKIPPED OUT ON
PAYING TAXES AND HE SUPPORTS THE
NEW ARMY OF IRS AGENTS, COMING
RIGHT IN THE COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND INTO YOUR
BUSINESS AND INTO YOUR TAX
RETURN.
OF COURSE HE'S NOT THE ONLY TAX
LOVING DEMOCRAT TO AVOIDS PAYING
HIS OWN TAXES.
AS SENATOR GEORGES RAPHAEL
WARNOCK COLLECTED AN EXTRA
$90,000 IN A TAX-FREE LOOPHOLE
AS A PARSONAGE ALLOWANCE FROM A
CHURCH.
HERSCHEL WALKER ALLEGEDLY PAYING
FOR AN ABORTION THAT HE DENIES,
THEY ARE IGNORING A TRULY
HORRIFIC SCANDAL SURROUNDING
HIM.
IN 2002 AS A MINISTER IN WEST
BALTIMORE, HE WAS ARRESTED FOR
OBSTRUCTING A POLICE
INVESTIGATION INTO CHILD ABUSE
AT HIS OWN CHURCH CAMP.
THE CHARGES WERE LATER DROPPED
BUT ACCORDING TO THE BALTIMORE
SUN HE AGGRESSIVELY REPEATEDLY
BLOCKED POLICE WERE INTERVIEWING
A CAMP COUNSELOR -- ONE OF THE
TROOPERS SAID I NEVER
ENCOUNTERED RESISTANCE LIKE THAT
AT ALL TALKING ABOUT YOUNG KIDS,
CHILD ABUSE.
FIVE CASES OF CHILD ABUSE WERE
BROUGHT AGAINST THE CAMP
DIRECTOR.
ONE FORMER CAMPER CLAIMS THAT
HIS CAMP COUNSELORS TOSSED ON A
12-YEAR-OLD BOY AND MADE OTHERS
SLEEP OUTSIDE IN THE COLD.
SADLY THIS IS NOT THE LAST TIME
HE WOULD HAVE TROUBLE WITH THE
LAW.
HE WAS ORDERED BY A SUPERIOR
COURT JUDGE TO ATTEND MEDIATION
AFTER HE WAS ACCUSED OF
NEGLECTING HIS OWN CHILDREN AND
FAILING TO PAY CHILD CARE
EXPENSES DESPITE AMASSING A
NETWORK OF NEARLY A MILLION
BUCKS.
IN 2020 HE WAS ACCUSED OF
RUNNING OVER HIS EX-WIFE'S FOOT
DURING A DOMESTIC DISPUTE AND
HERE'S WHAT HIS EX-WIFE SAID TO
POLICE AFTER THE INCIDENT.
>> THIS MAN IS RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
ALL HE CARES ABOUT IS HIS
REPUTATION.
I WORK AT THE MAYOR'S OFFICE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BE VERY
QUIET ABOUT THE WAY HE IS FOR
THE SAKE OF MY KIDS AND HIS
REPUTATION.
I'VE TRIED TO KEEP THE WAY HE
ACTS UNDER WRAPS FOR A LONG TIME
AND TODAY HE CROSSED THE LINE.
SO THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
HIM HE'S A GREAT ACTOR, HE IS
PHENOMENAL AT PUTTING ON A
REALLY GOOD SHOW.
>> Sean: CHILLING BUT THE
MEDIA MOB DOESN'T CARE AT ALL,
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT HIS PASTOR
DON'T CARE ABOUT HIS RADICAL
POLICIES LIKE DEFUNDING THE
POLICE THAT WILL HURT THE PEOPLE
OF GEORGIA.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR A WIN,
DON'T FALL FOR T